we've interviewed
a number of experts on the show people
familiar with
footage in the possession of the us
military who have said there is tape
out there of unidentified flying objects
descending from the sky
and then disappearing into the ocean
well today that video
emerged the pentagon has just confirmed
that the footage is real
you're seeing it now on your screen it
was taken by the combat information
center on board the uss omaha on july
15 2019 off the coast of san diego
as far as we know the ufo in question
was never recovered there was
no material indicating a crash
more than that we don't know tom rogan
is a washington examiner columnist
well versed in the subject he joins us
tonight tom what do you think
we're looking at here
well i think we may well be looking at a
true unknown which is to say
intelligently controlled machinery
that is not understood to be in the
possession
of the united states china or russia
which are the most
three most advanced uh countries in
terms of
um military uh aviation and and so
you know the video in and of itself is
is limiting what it can tell us but i
think it speaks
to as the pentagon itself has admitted
this continuing trend of of truly
unexplained things
um coming into the public consciousness
more than they have before
if you listen to this with the sound up
you can hear the guys
who are monitoring this video in real
time gasp
when it seems to disappear beneath the
wave so this kind of takes the weather
balloon off the table or some
meteorological phenomenon off the table
i mean
clearly we're looking at something that
is as you just put it being
intelligently controlled and it's going
underneath the ocean and then
disappearing
i mean you're we're sure that this could
not be a foreign nation
yes and that that is why you see um
people like senator rubio
leaning into the subject uh the military
office of naval intelligence which
really leads the military effort
researching this there isn't anything
that we have top secret information uh
about what china or russia have
or what we have at area 51 that can do
what these things do in terms of the
variable performance and i think
specifically relevant to this video in
the coming
months and years an area which we will
learn more about
uh is the interaction of u.s navy
submarines
nuclear ballistic missile submarines and
attack submarines
um picking up sonar contact of things
moving
um at hundreds of knots under the water
um
and so there is a undersea dimension to
this
uh that the navy has sort of pushed off
to the side
as the pilots uh talk more about their
experiences so
so there's a lot more to come out i
think is is the best way to put it
hundreds of knots under water i mean i
think all of us can imagine objects
moving at incredible speeds in the air
maybe even approaching
right you know the speed of light
potentially but hundreds of knots
under water i don't think most people
can even digest that
that's been recorded that that's
what i've heard from sources uh very
good sources and that the navy has the
data
and one of the big things tucker that i
think as we move towards this
um director of national intelligence
report
and i do know that the various agencies
are actually taking that more seriously
than people might expect
as is dni um one of the things we're
going to find is that over a period of
decades
a lot of the data a lot of the the
measurement
of these things um has been put off as
technical aberration
or essentially a data malfunction
because they didn't want to really admit
that
something very serious and special is
going on
i mean some of this behavior challenges
our understanding of physics so i think
this is going to
it's going to change a lot of
perceptions tom i appreciate it i hope
we'll see you again soon
thanks tucker hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else